Speaker 1: Hey, this is super interesting.
Newsmax is talking about Tulsi Gabbard as
Trump's running mate for 2024. And I have to
tell you, it makes a lot of sense. It really
does. So you might remember that yesterday, Tulsi
Gabbard on the first episode of her podcast,
what fortuitous timing announced that she's
leaving the Democratic Party now. Really,
for years, Tulsi had no business being
associated with the Democratic Party. She was
a contrarian, reactionary, with pseudo populist
right wing messaging, much more aligned with MAGA
world than with any Democrats that I know.
She now officially has left the Democratic
Party and is becoming an independent.
And here is Greg Kelly on Newsmax saying,
what about Tulsi as Trump's running mate?
Speaker 6: Tulsi Gabbard, she quit the
Democrat Party today and did it
in spectacular fashion. The former
Democratic congresswoman from Hawaii is now.
Speaker 1: And by the way, we looked at the
video bye bye. Spectacular fashion. She did it
with conspiracy theories about elitist cabals
and false claims about what the left believes.
Speaker 6: Dependent and I believe could very
well be a future running mate for Donald Trump.
Whoa. All right. So she quit on the first episode
of her new podcast. Take a look. Now. I love our
country, our God given rights of freedom, life and
liberty that are enshrined in our Constitution
and Bill of Rights are what inspires me.
All right. She's just warming up. You realize,
though, that statement about the Constitution,
a reference for our Bill of Rights.
How this makes her persona non grata
in the Democrat Party. This is radical.
Speaker 1: Stuff for them. Actually, her
completely reactionary conspiratorial statements
and false claims about anti-white racism woke and
an elitist cabal are what make her not at home
in the Democratic Party. Now, I have to tell you,
it makes way more sense that she
would be Trump's running mate. I mean,
think about it. They're on the same page about,
oh, the left is all about being against faith
and against religion and all of they want to
be racist to white people. It makes a ton of
sense that she would be Trump's running mate.
And that's why we can tell. It never really
made sense that she was a Democrat. There was this
vague idea, Oh, she's against regime change wars.
Okay. And that made her what special in some
way. Most people are against regime change
wars when they agree about what the regime change
wars are. But there was really nothing else that
made her at all interesting to the Democratic
Party or as a Democrat. And so I don't think
she's actually going to be Trump's running
mate, but she would be much more at home
there as a MAGA reactionary than she has been
in the Democratic Party for a very long time.